when I was in Northern Norway not so
long ago I went to see one of Norway's
Main Headquarters an impressive
headquarters deep in the Rock safe and
sound but a proper military headquarters
that is really important for the work we
both do
we share incredibly common
vulnerabilities and strengths we are
obviously parts of the North Sea where
our critical infrastructure our gas and
oil fields exist or coexist and of
course that is very often in the path of
the Russian Navy and as we've seen even
last week the week before the Russian
Navy come down through between our two
countries into the North Sea and
obviously the range of of hulls that the
Russians sometimes deploy range from Spy
ships to surface ships to
submarines and that means we have to
work together as NATO Partners some of
the oldest NATO Partners together to
make sure that we protect that Northern
flank and also protect our crystallized
infrastructure and also we shouldn't
forget that as Europe migrates away from
Russian gas
Norway becomes even more of Europe's
critical National infrastructure
Norway's gas amounts for I think about
40 percent of European gas you know it's
not just in the interest of Britain and
Norway it's in the interest of Europe to
make sure that those infrastructures and
energy supplies are not vulnerable to a
rusher who is getting more and more
aggressive and so the joint working
today what I've taken Beyond to see in
the maritimes operations center
demonstrates that joint working and how
we help coordinate each other's
responses is a really important part of
the work we do and exploring today what
more we can do and we signed another
agreement to do more together to share
more together to improve both our
intelligence sharing and indeed some of
our capabilities
and together also we work together on
our industrial basis and acquiring their
capability recently the British Navy
bought the new anti-ship missile the NSM
the Norwegian which is a fantastic Best
in Class anti-ship missile I'm delighted
it is starting to be fitted onto our
type 23s and type 45s lethality was one
of the gaps on our surface Fleet I was
also delighted when I visited a factory
in the north of England that some parts
of every of that missile are also made
in the United Kingdom so I think it's
another sign of great partnership so
thank you very much for last Bjorn to
say something and then we'll open to
questions
well thank you and let me start by
thanking my very good call again friend
Ben for the invitation to Norfolk and
Norway and United Kingdom have a long
history of friendship and partnership
and the UK is Norway's most important
European Ally
Russia's war against Ukraine has brought
us even closer together Russia's use of
military force have direct implications
also for Norway and the situation in the
high North
it is important for democracies to stand
together when the rule-based
international order is under pressure
therefore there is also an increased
need for close military cooperation
between allies not at least at sea and
today's meeting
meetings have clearly shown a common
understanding and a common desire to
further enhance our bilateral defense
cooperation
the sabotage of the north stream
pipelines last year is a clear reminder
of what is at stake here
our signing today is therefore very
important
by working together we can improve our
abilities to detect submarines counter
mind threats and to protect critical
infrastructure on the seabed
let me take the opportunity to
congratulate even on the UK's new
multi-role ocean surveillance vessel
such a capacity will be of great use in
protecting critical infrastructure
and today we also agreed to continue and
and to strengthen our support to Ukraine
I will say that the United Kingdom has a
long and proud history of International
Leadership in crisis
you have taken a strong stance to
support the ukrainians in their
Justified of freedom and sovereignty the
role United Kingdom plays is a white
hole
you act as a catalyst for donations from
partners and allies and for this United
Kingdom and uban you deserve credit and
our gratitude
they are working closely together in
this support both financially through
the international fund for Ukraine and
Military through operation interflex
Norway is a substantial contributor to
the fund and we can contribute to the
training of Ukrainian soldiers both in
the United Kingdom and in Norway and
from the samurai Norway will double our
number of instructors in operation
interflex
we also work together to maximize our
efforts concerning donations or weapons
and ammunitions
and today we are confirming the delivery
of long-range artillery and Raiders
Norway provides three arter artillery
location railers and up to eight
long-range rocket artillery of the mlrs
type
these donations are made in close
collaboration with the United Kingdom
this will be significant contributions
to the Ukrainian defense and show the
determination of our governments
to stand together in our support for the
Ukrainian people
thank you thank you Bjorn um I'll call
people
for questions the I'll do British
Norwegian British Norwegian so uh Sky
News
thank you um Deborah Haynes from Sky
um could you just say has the UK seen
any evidence that South Africa has
provided weapons to Russia and are you
able to say whether or not Storm Shadow
has been used yet in Ukraine and against
what and for the Norwegian Minister and
are you able to say whether it's more
likely than not that Russia was linked
in some way to the nordstream attack and
is this new agreement with the UK today
going to make it much less likely that a
nordstream attack can happen again in
the future
so that
look on the first point I'm I can't
comment on uh you know anything uh that
I may or may not have seen relating to
another country
if it isn't a public statement by those
countries so I I don't think I'm afraid
it falls into the neither confirm or
deny anything in that area on the Storm
Shadow all I can say is it is my
understanding that it has been used
uh since we announced its deployment to
Ukraine but I'm not going to go any
further details of that operationally
yeah and I can't uh really say anything
particular about the north streams
attack there has been on it ongoing
investigation I think LED from Sweden
and Denmark
when we signed this agreement today it's
because
there is a lot of infrastructure on the
seabed in our part of Europe
and we need to protect this as Ben said
you know Norway is the largest supplier
of energy of gas to to the continent and
today
and also to the United Kingdom
we have been working after North stream
attacks to
to monitor this infrastructure
the maritime command has been very
important and in in we have been working
with close allies to to monitor the
situation both
subsea and at sea
but we it's a ongoing work and we have
to look at how we can be even better to
Monitor and protect this important
infrastructure
uh forgive my pronunciation cry
for nrk
in
for you Mr Wallace
um how do you think the relationship
with Norway has changed since the
invasion of Ukraine
and also if I may
um do you think Norway is doing enough
for Ukraine being a financially strong
country and also in possession of F-16
aircrafts
but
first of all at one level it hasn't
changed in so far as we are a very very
old Ally often for decades we have
shared the the weight and the
responsibility of the northern Fleet
sort of guard the the two countries that
you know always were on the front line
of that Northern Fleet coming out of the
barrancy of in the Cold War and
obviously since and so that that is a
really old and deep relationship on
maritime operations I think what Ukraine
has showed us is the importance of
intelligence sharing and working even
closer and more dynamically together in
a world that is you know 20 2023 rather
than something 30 years ago and you know
when we've been working with the jeff
which has gone from strength to strength
you know Britain and Norway are one of
the key members of the Jeff and being
able to either host exercises work
together alongside to coordinate that
response you know we both feel we have a
an obligation to two newest potential
members of Norway certainly Finland and
hopefully soon Sweden you know we're the
oldest members of NATO I think sitting
in in that region and so we have a sort
of paternal a love of those two
countries and want to make sure that
they um come into NATO working to
improve their defenses but also for us
to help each other in that Mutual
defense so I I think it's just reminded
us of the strength of our friendship but
also the importance of that friendship
and now we have an extra Duty which is
the husbandrying into NATO of Sweden and
Finland
and there's no way doing enough for
Ukraine I think noise doing a lot for
Ukraine I think Norway has not only been
the lead contributor to the
international fund which we have now
into the second phase of funding weapons
and and requirements for Ukraine they
were a big big donation into I think 250
million Euros or million euros a big
donation in the first round and that's
been really really important the m270s
the gmrs that bjorns talked about
there's only three nations that have
really helped this happen Germany
Britain the United States and Norway are
four nations without Norway we couldn't
have gifted ours and now obviously the
extra Edition and they are really potent
weapon systems that if you look over the
last 18 months the weapon system that
caused the most problem to Russia in the
middle of the year in its advance and
held it back was the high miles and the
m270 potent weapons that had really
really made a difference and then on
interflex as we call it the training of
ukrainians not very far from where I
live right from the start I've seen the
Norwegians training up in the north of
England the ukrainians they've just a
really welcome pledge just at the right
time doubling uh to over a hundred
Norwegian service Personnel training are
trading the ukrainians that's really
really important and comes at just the
right time so I think they're doing
absolutely just enough and more
and they should have won the Eurovision
song contest you were robbed
uh okay uh dawn of the Beale
um could I just pick up on you I mean I
understand why you don't want to go into
huge detail about Storm Shadow but can
you just tell us whether it was just the
once it's been used whether it did what
it was intended to do
um and and just if you can explain a bit
as to why you felt it was so important
to deliver these I mean we know that
Ukraine's about to launch an offensive
but these are key element of that are
these last last pieces in the jigsaw as
far as you're concerned and then I just
to be clear on the on the underwater
cables I mean you know you can't say
that
the Russia was behind the Nordstrom
attack so so just just to be clear who
is the threat to the underwater cables
what evidence is there that Russia might
have done something and makes you
worried to do something yourselves about
it and then finally for Norwegian
defense minister uh just a cheeky last
question f-16s you have f-16s you're
replacing them or you've replaced most
of them I think with f-35s will you be
giving f-16s to Ukraine and would you
Ben Willis encourage them to do that
thank you have you got any more
questions John that's it I just really
want to know
um no I I'm afraid I can disappoint you
on the Storm Shadow I'm not going to go
into any more detail I can tell you why
it was important for the ukrainians to
have that deeper strike capability uh
the high miles in the m270 had made a
very significant difference to the
ukrainians on the battlefield to the
extent that the Russians were moving
many of their Commander control centers
out of that range and and that's why
it's important to to go know where those
those command and control centers go
that that helps Ukraine in the in in the
key moments if they can obviously Target
in the deep and it's also one of the
mitigations that if you can't provide
fighter aircraft can you help provide
one of the things that photo aircraft
deliver which is deep strike and yes we
can we can do that with Storm Shadow
that gives you the range that in other
methods you can use with an aircraft you
can do it with a Storm Shadow missile so
it was important uh very much to do that
look on on the from my point of view on
the critlash infrastructure the cables
and the gas pipelines what we know is
the Russians have a rope program they
have a specific Naval program
designed to both look at and potentially
sabotage or attack critical National
infrastructure belonging to its
adversaries the it has a number of
submarines and other pieces of equipment
and spy ships and everything else
specifically designed for that purpose
so whether we're talking about Nordstrom
whether we're talking about our own
infrastructure that is an area that is
vulnerable and needs to be protected
that's why in July our first ship the
emerald ship which is RFA Proteus will
go to see to start patrolling and I
fully expect a large part of the area
that it will Patrol will be Norway and
the United Kingdom it's an area where
our gas pipelines are where our wind
farms are where are electronic cables
and optic cables are that'll be its job
so what we can say without doubt is
Russia has the intent and the capability
to Target the West's critical
infrastructure we have to have the
intent and the capability to defend it
was there another question
well first to the with like my
say a few words to the first question
then now Russia has attacked a peaceful
neighbor we are a neighbor
it's another whole other security
situation in Europe now uh and we have
seen how energy has been used
in this conflict
and as we have already talked about the
Strategic importance of this
infrastructure
is very high so we need to protect it
and that's that's why we are working
continuously on this and that's why we
also have signed another agreement today
to to protect this infrastructure
when it comes to F16 I I really don't
want it's it's not on the agenda now and
I I really don't want to speculate in
any possible future donations
Tonya
of tb2
who's stolen the microphone
can you say something about the current
threat to the energy infrastructure and
what exactly you want to do to secure
the underwater infrastructure and also
if I may can you say something about the
importance of this agreement
Georgia
well uh if I I can start then
the agreement is both about
operating Better Together to see how we
how our our resources can be much even
better to see how we can
to Monitor and protect this
infrastructure and also look and how we
can develop future capabilities
to have even better technology and
capabilities to protect this
infrastructure so this supplement the
ongoing work that we already are doing
the cooperation we have and we we try to
find even better ways to cooperate and
develop the capabilities to to protect
our our infrastructure
and also an agreement you know further
exploring where we have common
capabilities that we need to develop
together which is obviously important we
we work together on things like
uh the the NSM missile system there's
plenty of industrial opportunities
between the two of us to explore where
there are requirements obviously sync at
the same time which is I think important
but also that ongoing commitment to
explore more joint working and exercises
and everything else and I think I think
that's that's really why it's quite
important that we we continue that
direction of travel for integration
okay and other questions before
Tony Fox
Robert Fox Robert Fox
um Minister both can we go back on
cables and the threats there you were
talking about the Russian agency I
suspect you uh referring to googie gugi
have you seen a real step change in
their activities since the Ukrainian
Crisis began in February last year
because there was the warning from the
Irish authorities about the close
attention that was being paid to the
communication nodes of the cables coming
coming ashore and do you see further
activity around the northern Cape this
is specifically for Norway as the Baltic
is becoming increasingly closed with the
accession of Finland and possibly Sweden
to Nato so there's a very very narrow
International channel uh strategically
speaking into Petersburg
thank you
first of all right the northern Fleet is
Russia's most capable naval fleet uh up
in the baron sea and uh in a mansk and
all that part of the old that that is a
part of that big Navy basing obviously
the Russian capabilities on the land are
being decimated Putin will still have a
Navy still have a sizable Air Force also
up in that part of the world is some of
the highest concentration of nuclear
warheads uh and you're absolutely right
Robert to make the point about the
narrowing point between Finland and the
bulk means that uh Russia has probably
less options but one of the options uh
are over in our part of the world and
that's why it's even more important that
we double down and lots of other nations
play their part Bjorn was telling me how
the Germans and the French engage as
well up there their critical apps
infrastructure and the energy is now you
know our infrastructure to everyone's
interest that that is not uh in a
position of of vulnerability uh right
about the googie the program whichever
you would like to call it
um
we haven't seen a massive uptick as yet
because they had the fire if you
remember they had a fire on uh
reportedly on on their submarine and
that delayed significantly there were a
number of significant deaths on that
um and obviously they had to rebuild or
regenerate that capability they are
starting to regenerate that capability
we have seen more activity we fully
expect it to return but also they have a
very active service surface Fleet as
well and it was only a couple of weeks
ago that some of those sort of spy ship
type ships that we often see reported
were active around the British and
Norwegian coasts and and definitely that
has stepped up their activity around us
really going back to 2020 when they sent
a kilo class submarine down the Irish
sea for the first time ever has has
grown and we don't see that changing and
and their overall activity of their
submarine Fleet is greater than it has
been for some time
George
thanks very much uh George girls from
the times
um you talked about how Russia has this
dedicated program and has done for some
while and has stepped up its activity in
recent years How likely do you think it
is that they have already sabotaged our
underwater infrastructure do we know for
certain that they haven't
um and then specifically to the
Secretary of State I'm not sure if
you've seen But as part of Sarah
atherton's inquiry there's been a lot of
evidence published if which is familiar
to lots of us about women experiencing
sexual assault in the armed forces she's
once again mentioned bringing rape and
sexual assault cases into civilian
courts
um
what's your response to that so I know
there's a report being published today I
I haven't read it I've been in meetings
all day and here so I'm happy to give a
comment once I've read it look
the newest figures on rape and murder
and routes are actually better outcomes
now in the military system it also I'm
afraid but it we have taken very strong
Taps I think we implemented 35 of her 36
recommendations now anyone who's ever
followed parliamentary committee
inquiries you point any other government
Minister that has implemented so many
recommendations of our back benches
inquiry and you'll find it's very rare
it will take time we've put in place we
opened about 18 months ago the serious
crime unit where we brought together
better expertise critical mass to
improve the quality of the
investigations we put in the henrique's
report many of the recommendations there
we're going to put in some new offenses
around instructors relationships in
different parts of training we removed
from the chain of command service
complaints criminal complaints were
always outside the chain of command but
we've now removed service complaints
we've strengthened the ombudsman's role
but those things will take time to come
through some of the uh cases that we see
in the media are historical not all of
them but some of them are and I can't do
much about some things that happen in
the 80s and the 90s but I can certainly
make sure that they are better dealt
with whenever they come about when
they're brought to our attention and you
know we've strengthened even now I only
recently I looked at the
the mou or the agreement between the
Civil prosecution and the and the
service Prosecuting Authority about When
Trials take place in different courts
and and when it will be when it will be
done so it is not mandated but it is
absolutely an mou between the two
Prosecuting authorities but ultimately
the bigger challenge here is the
cultural challenge as well right and
I've been very clear about having to
deal with that it's not easy uh you know
it doesn't happen overnight but we
should also make sure that we recognize
that there are other people women in the
Army who've had a fantastic experience
and I know their voices are crowded out
by the very disturbing events that
happen to some people who quite rightly
need a deserve a better service and
better support and historically probably
haven't had it but there are also people
having women having fulfilling careers
doing successful things in the armed
forces and I just want to you know point
out that I went to visit Santos recently
part of that process of making sure we
change the culture but also speaking to
female Cadets about their experiences
and yes things are changing and getting
better but you know I put a huge amount
of effort in adopting Sarah atherton's
recommendations the only one we differed
was because there was no real evidence
that in the that after all the measures
we put in place that that would somehow
make the difference the key here is that
we take complaints seriously they're
dealt with without fear or favor there
isn't undue influence the chain of
commanders removed from it and the
quality of the investigation is such
that we get the conviction rate that we
need
on on that area what was your first
questions under
I I'm not going to speculate on on our
levels of knowledge of the Russian rope
system I think that would only help
Russia but I think the reality is we
have to be alert to our vulnerabilities
and we have to be alert to the
deliberate program that Russians have
invested in and we must do the same
if I may add a couple of words there
when it comes to infrastructure is of
course difficult to give guarantees we
have almost 9 000 kilometers of gas
pipelines on the bottom of the sea uh
but we have and I won't go into details
but we have been working
the Armed Forces with the companies on
the shelves uh uh the private sector the
last months in
getting a good overview of the situation
A situational awareness
in addition to that that we constantly
above sea level are patrolling and are
present to making sure that the
there will be no activity that threatens
these Pipelines
good so
is that the last one
thank you very much and Jack Allison
from the Sun there's obviously been lots
of sort of talk about an imminent spring
offensive as a turning point for the
ukrainians
um but where do you think we are in the
timeline of this war are we at the early
stages with many years of fighting ahead
or you know it's their light at the end
of the tunnel and secondly uh
specifically to the executive State
um yesterday your old boss Liz truss
said that Britain should officially
declare China as a threat
um was this helpful and do you agree
with her
uh on on China are the government
positions consistent uh we view them as
a challenge and a competition uh at
present of course we differ
significantly on their views of
human rights and indeed their views of
democracy uh
I think obviously Liz is trying to ask
us to go one step further for now our
position is very similar to the United
States position and its latest security
strategy and of course we won't back
down for standing up for international
rules such as the rule of the Sea The
Law of the sea that we often test and
indeed assert as being very important
yeah
well I mean we're as far as President
Putin wants to go I mean he's uh on the
receiving end of over 250 000 dead or
injured of his own troops over ten
thousand armored vehicles destroyed or
captured he's low on his stocks uh his
International reputation is pretty much
trashed on the rocks and he is still
pressing on so I'm afraid to say at the
moment Russia still seems determined no
matter what the cost to their own people
and that's why it's important that
Ukraine is not only given the tools to
defend itself but also to go to the next
step of expelling Russia from its
borders I'm not going to speculate when
they will do that we are on the right
trajectory of their capability their
training their weapon systems and thank
you to Norway for more donations but the
the two people in charge of that Destiny
is Ukraine and Russia
thank you very much everybody thank you